[Musique]
je m'appelle lemony snicket c'est moi le
contôle a fait et je me trouve dans
toute ma ce plan devant ce qui ne peut
qu'être décrit comme une série d'
opportunité inespérée le désastreuse
aventure sur le point de connaître une
issue délicieux lisieux merci prenne fin
et c'est bien dommage nous avions
commencé je vous le donne en mille par
le commencement j'ai eu une mauvaise
nouvelle à vous annoncer les enfants
votre maison est détruite et vous êtes
orphelins à présent à présent à
prétendent indices qui se sont révélés
trompeur de performance exceptionnel
d'un cent dix superflu d'incidents
providentiel de comportement erratique
d'expériences enrichissantes d'échappées
belles des sectes puissant et
épouvantables conditions climatiques
tout vous sera bientôt révélé le fort de
baudelaire et la vérité cachée derrière
les lettres uvf idée parce que chers
téléspectateurs et mes très chers fans
le dénouement est proche
mais par chance pas de chance